before the lease was supposed to get  signed partner couldn't come up with  half the money to do the gym the night  before i ended up assuming the entire  gym how much did that cost so it was  supposed to be both we're gonna put 25  grand in and i had 60. it went from  me having some padding to no padding so  it was 50 grand i had 60. and so i had  10 000 left which is enough for two  months rent at that gym so i started  sleeping at the gym because i couldn't  afford two rents i remember selling the  entire first month and making exactly 4  973 which is the exact amount of the  rent and so then i just watched it go  back down to zero and i was like this  sucks  the next month we made 10 grand the next  month made 15 then 20 and 20. it was  like 5 grand a month all the way up to  like 35 000 a month i started hiring  people and bringing people in and then  by month like nine it was all outsourced  so i had the like a manager and some  trainers and whatnot